I heard that you Carol growing up I did
too yes did you do like the full-on
costumes well we didn't do you did no I
thought I thought that maybe you did I
always wanted to look like I'm in a
Charles Dickens thing just like going
around singing a Holy Night do that we
should do that just for and we should
get other artists and just show up we do
this I'm like legitimately signing up
this group right now I'm not even
kidding I want to wear a I already know
people I can call that will do it yes
yes fullon costume okay I I I want a
bonnet what's one of your favorites
though cuz I know you did Carol I did I
I a lot of caroling and I there's so
many Christmas songs that I absolutely
love um but I really love the winter
wonderland like a super
classic yeah it makes you feel
good they're ready you're
ready give yourself a
hand I love Christmas so much you do and
I tell you what like this city I'm so
excited I've never lived here during
Christmas I've been here like working
but never lived I am very excited I'm
going to be annoying it's going to be a
different level it is like so I grew up
in a small town in northern California
and to your point earlier about like I
that was the only way I saw theater was
like if it was on TV or whatever so we
like we have a little town and but we
didn't there was no decorations in the
Macy's we didn't have a Macy it's kind
of warmer right like yeah yeah yeah we
wouldn't never get snow so it's really
fun to be around like the proper winter
and get hat and scarf absolutely wet
Dive
[Music]
[Applause]
Right thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home